Julie Stout: And we are now recording. Okay, today is March 6th, 2026. My name is Julie Stout, and I'm here with.
Rick March: Richard March, otherwise known as Rick March.
Julie Stout: There you go. And we are doing our first of our interviews regarding the Dawson Gary project, Richard Dawson, and any other materials that we want to talk about. But first, I really want to start with the biographical questions for you.
Rick March: I want to add, though, that I'm in Portland, Oregon.
Julie Stout: Yes, thank you.
Julie Stout: Richard is in Portland, Oregon, and I am currently in Bloomington, Indiana. Thank you.
Julie Stout: So, to start off, can you tell me your preferred full name and pronunciation?
Rick March: Formally, Richard March, and more informally, Rick March.
Julie Stout: Me neither.
Rick March: And I seldom use my middle names unless, required.
Julie Stout: Yep, that's fair, that's fair. How old are you today, and what is your date of birth?
Rick March: I'm 79.
Rick March: My date of birth is December 24, 1946.
Julie Stout: Christmas Eve.
Rick March: Christmas Eve, baby.
Julie Stout: There you go. And where were you born? City, state, and then country?
Rick March: I was born in Chicago, Illinois, USA.
Julie Stout: And…
Julie Stout: So, this part you can answer how you'd like, but it is, could you tell me about your family life and childhood, including your parents' slash guardians and their occupations, and siblings, if you have any?
Rick March: Sure, yes, my,
Rick March: I guess I'll back up a little bit. My mother was an immigrant to the United States from an area that's now Croatia. When she was born, it was Austria-Hungary, then later it was under Italy, and then part of Yugoslavia, and now part of Croatia. So.
Rick March: People who have lived in that same village have been in four countries without moving anywhere, over the last century.
Rick March: So,
Rick March: you know, she, her family settled on the south side of Chicago, which of course is the home to the big meatpacking industry.
Rick March: My father was born in,
Rick March: in Brooklyn, New York, he was of Eastern European Jewish background, combination of what they call Litvak, family… his family was from around Minsk, in what's now Belarus, and his mother's family was from Krakow, in the southern part of Poland.
Rick March: So he, he wound up, becoming a political radical and a labor organizer, and he wound up,
Rick March: organizing, at first in Kansas City, and then in Chicago, where he had a multiple-decade career as a labor organizer working in the packing houses, and then became a union official. My mother was a community activist who,
Rick March: worked in the community organization called Back of the Yards Council, helped found it. Saul Alinsky, who became famous as a
Rick March: like a mentor of Barack Obama, or, you know, indirectly, was, a friend of my dad's and mom's, and, you know, my, my mom,
Rick March: the women who did all the grunt work in the organizing were happy in that era to just let Saul Linsky as a male take all the credit for it. But, so anyway, I come out of that kind of a background.
Rick March: And, I have two older brothers,
Rick March: My brother Bob was born in 1934, my brother Bill was born in 1939, and then there was a bit of a gap, because my mother worked in a war plant during World War II, and so I wasn't born until after the war, 1946.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: My grandmother lived in my household most of the time that I was growing up. She sometimes would go and live with one of my aunts or uncles, but more of the time she lived with my mother, who was the youngest daughter.
Rick March: She was… my mother was the youngest of 13 children who were born to my grandmother. 11 survived infancy, so,
Rick March: You know, there was a higher infant mortality rate in those days.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: As a result, my… my grandfather had come, as kind of a refugee to,
Rick March: the U.S. in 1912.
Rick March: Things were leading up to World War I, and there were some political hassles that caused him to leave, and he wasn't able to send for, his wife and his youngest kids until 1921.
Rick March: When he… he was a shoemaker and a shoe repair guy, and developed a business on the south side of Chicago, and he… when he finally felt he had enough assets, and the war was over, you know, the war lasted until 1918,
Rick March: 1921, he was able to bring… bring my mother and my aunt and uncle, the youngest ones.
Rick March: From the village. And since my… my grandmother was over 50 years old when she arrived in the U.S, and had only spoken Croatian to that point.
Rick March: She did learn some English, but
Rick March: was never fluent in it, and so we spoke Croatian in my household growing up because my grandmother was there.
Rick March: And then there were… there was a continuing filtering of more relatives, an aunt of mine who had remained in the home village until the 1950s.
Rick March: Her, husband had died, and so as a widow, she came to live with us in, like, 1957 or 8.
Rick March: When I was in junior high school, as we called middle school most days.
Rick March: And she lived in our household for a while, until her son
Rick March: came from the old country, about 1960, 61, so we were continually having this influx of relatives from the old country who spoke the home language, and it kept it alive in our family, although we spoke English
Rick March: a whole lot of the time, too, because my dad, although he got so he could kind of understand the Croatian, you know, he… he… his parents had spoken Yiddish, and he had grown up speaking mainly just English.
Rick March: So anyway, so it was a bilingual household.
Rick March: Now,
Rick March: We… we, my dad was one of the… one of the main leaders of the union, the CIO-founded union in the packing houses, and if you know anything about labor history, the AFL unions and the CIO unions
Rick March: had a kind of a different political trajectory. The CIO unions were industry-wide, whereas the AFFL unions were more craft-based and more conservative.
Rick March: Anyway, there's a lot of union politics, and then there was the, McCarthy period, the red baiting period, and laws passed.
Rick March: That, you know, made it difficult for my dad to remain in the union movement in Chicago. So…
Rick March: Some of my relatives, my aunts and uncles, had moved out to California because, actually some of their eldest siblings had been on the West Coast working as fishermen, off the, you know, tuna fishermen and, shipyard workers.
Rick March: on the West Coast, And so, we moved to Los Angeles.
Rick March: When I was, 9 years old.
Rick March: And, .
Julie Stout: From Chicago, the.
Rick March: From Chicago, because my dad, it became an untenable situation politically to remain in the Union.
Rick March: As an officer, and, he went out to, you know, Los Angeles.
Rick March: He had some friends who were in the Sheet Metal Workers Union who got him into their apprenticeship program. He worked for a while as a construction worker in sheet metal, but he wound up studying law at night, and eventually got his law degree.
Rick March: Because he had been,
Rick March: before, there was a… there was a congressional committee called the House Un-American Activities Committee that, you know, was a way of smearing and persecuting, radicals, and he had
Rick March: been subpoenaed to testify before them a couple of times. The California Bar Association initially didn't accept my dad, and he had to…
Rick March: file a suit that ultimately the California State Supreme Court ordered the… the Bar Association to admit him, so he eventually became a lawyer. But, already, you know, when he was, like, over 50. So,
Rick March: So anyway, my mother, when we moved out to California, she had been working as an interviewer. Chicago has a, you know, we live in the neighborhood of the University of Chicago, and
Rick March: there's a long tradition of social research, a big sociology department, a social work department, and so she had gotten work when my dad was unemployed, going around interviewing people, you know, it was all pretty much done in person in those days. Telephone interviews hadn't really started yet.
Rick March: That came a little later.
Rick March: So, when we moved to California, she started a business, the… a marketing research business.
Rick March: Most of the market research firms were in the East Coast, New Jersey, New York.
Rick March: And the California market was just emerging at that time in the mid to late 50s as a trendsetter in U.S, you know, market developments.
Rick March: And so, you know, her business was quite successful. She got contracts from these firms, Market Facts is one that I remember the name of.
Rick March: And, she would hire
Rick March: interviewers. And a lot of the interviewers were kind of people in the political radical circles that she had been in who were blacklisted, and she was able to hire them
Rick March: To… usually they were pretty educated people who, were able to do this kind of work that involved a degree of literacy, you know, to do good interviews.
Rick March: So growing up, growing up, my, I was used to the fact that we were constantly sent
Rick March: big boxes of… in those days, they were mimeographed questionnaires, and and she'd, you know, give, you know, the quantity assigned to each interviewer, brief them on how to do the thing. Sometimes there were product placements, you know, they'd have unlabeled
Rick March: tubes of toothpaste, and you'd have to ask people which flavor they preferred. Or I remember flavored yogurt came out as a new product in those days, and so that was fun. I enjoyed eating the samples that didn't get sent out with the interviewers.
Rick March: So, you know, it was that kind of a business and that kind of set that the new car time was very busy, and I remember my parents… my dad would actually work for my mom sometimes at real busy times, because sheet metal work was seasonal.
Rick March: You know, in more rainy season and stuff, less construction was going on in those days, and so she'd hire him, in the fall when the new
Rick March: car models would come out, and they, you know, that was a big… so anyways, that was kind of gives you a little bit of a flavor of what was going on in our household. Now.
Julie Stout: About what time period was the California era?
Rick March: We moved to California in 1955.
Julie Stout: Okay.
Rick March: And I lived there, until 1969.
Rick March: After I graduated from University of California.
Julie Stout: But we'll, we'll get to that.
Rick March: So, you know, I was in… we were located in the Hollywood neighborhood. It was fairly central.
Rick March: We had a bunch… our relatives were all down in the harbor area, San Pedro, California, because they were, like, the ones that were working in the fishing industry, fish canning, and so on and so forth. And for me, as a kid, it was really like two different worlds. We'd get on the car, drive down Figueroa Boulevard till we got to San Pedro.
Rick March: And all of a sudden, we were in this very ethnic scene, whereas up in Hollywood, you know, that was the center of the entertainment industry, especially in that era. The Paramount Studios were just up the street from our house.
Rick March: the… what had been RKO Studios, but then was bought out by Lucille Ball and Desi Arnaz as the Desilu Studios. They were making, TV programs. That was all up there. And one of the things to know about Hollywood
Rick March: is that the… what's called the Flatlands of Hollywood, not up in the hills.
Rick March: was the working class section of Hollywood, where there are lots of people that worked in the film industry, but not in the, you know, that were gaffers, the ones that often didn't get any credits at all, that were filmed.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: that were, musicians in big, studio orchestras that, and, and also, again, these were seasonal jobs. You'd get a work, you'd get work on a particular film while it was going on, and then you'd get laid off.
Julie Stout: When the…
Rick March: So, we lived… we lived in the Flatlands, in the more working-class section of Hollywood, but where I went to Hollywood High.
Rick March: A majority of people from the
Rick March: You know, more, you know, the more wealthy people.
Rick March: they either sent their kids to private school, or they moved a little farther west into Beverly Hills, so the kids went to Beverly Hills High, or, you know, places like that. So Hollywood High had a certain percentage of people that were from these, these, you know.
Rick March: show business families, but, not that many, not that many. Like, you know, and I can…
Rick March: there were… there were people that, you know, through Family Connections, like John Ritter, became a… on… was on TV in this thing called Three's Company, which was a comedy about a guy with two female roommates, whatever. He was… his dad, Tex Ritter, was a cowboy singer, you know.
Rick March: There are lots of examples of that, but I won't go into them.
Julie Stout: So an interesting, like, demographic class, like, mixing in your schools and everything.
Rick March: Well, you know, I… I… you mean… I'm not sure I understand the question, let me.
Julie Stout: Oh, yeah, sorry, because you mentioned that there were some kids who were, like, from, like, show families, like, show business families, and then some people who weren't. And I basically just made a comment, like, would you say that, like, the class, like, economic class difference, like, between kids, as well, because different families and.
Rick March: Oh yeah, of course.
Julie Stout: In your schools. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, so… so most of the, most of the kids at, at, Hollywood High were from kind of middle-class families.
Julie Stout: people that worked city, but there were some from kind of lower middle class whose parents were on the edges of the entertainment industry and were laid off often, like.
Rick March: A lot of times, I remember I had a friend whose… whose dad
Rick March: was, you know, sometimes the director of soap opera things, and and then, you know, he'd… they'd be… they'd be poor for a while, then he, oh, good, my dad got a new soapy, and now we're… now we're… now we're earning steady income again. You know.
Julie Stout: Interesting, yeah.
Rick March: So, you know, people don't really understand, you know, outside, you say Hollywood, okay, it's this glitzy world, you know, and a certain aspect of it was, but we were actually, as kids, very skeptical of that. We thought it was ridiculous that all these
Rick March: you know, out-of-towners came in and would go on these… there were these van tours to see stars' homes. They'd drive up into the Hollywood Hills, or Beverly Hills, or Brentwood, and, oh, you know, that's the house where, you know, Marlon Brando lived, or, you know, some of the type of stars from that era.
Rick March: And and then there'd be these premieres when a new movie would come out, and you'd see these spotlights in the sky,
Rick March: And, so, you know, one of my cousins, Gloria, lived down in Santa Monica. She was a big, you know, reader of movie magazines, and so she liked to go, so sometimes, you know, I went with her. They'd wear a lot of red carpet in front of the movie theater, Grauman's Chinese, or, you know, Pantages, one of these big, you know, theaters.
Rick March: And then the stars of the movie would be dropped off, you know, from limousines, and walk down the red carpet, and, you know, there'd be, there'd be ropes holding people back, and guess, oh, wow, I, you know, got to see John Wayne, you know?
Julie Stout: And they still did those tours today.
Rick March: And… and we… we… kids who were in that… we were very cynical about all that, because you always, as a teenager, think that the place where you live is the… the stupidest place in the world, or something, you know?
Rick March: So anyway, you know, yeah, so I, I, I did, I grew up, I grew up in my teen years in, in Hollywood, and but I had this ethnic side of my life.
Rick March: where, you know, my family belonged to something called Croatian Fraternal Union. You know, you'd buy some insurance, and then you would remember this ethnic lodge.
Julie Stout: Alright.
Rick March: and they would hold lamb roast picnics, and they would have, Croatian music played on these tambarica instruments, and, you know, some couple, especially my Aunt Tonka, she was an avid dancer, you know, in these round dances and stuff.
Rick March: my mother was a member of a Croatian singing choir for, you know, several years. You know, so there was that aspect of our lives.
Rick March: And, The other thing that I did.
Rick March: is, because of the packinghouse Union connection, there was a guy who had moved out to Central California, who my dad had known from the union. He had been in Missouri, and he and his wife
Rick March: were running a farm near Watsonville, California, and my parents, when I was, like, 10 years old, went up to visit them.
Rick March: And, They had a chicken farm, egg, eggs, you know, not for meat, but eggs.
Rick March: And, so they stayed for, you know, a long weekend, and they were getting ready to go home, and it was summertime, and I said, oh, can I stay? Can I stay? And, so Bob and Beth Pepper said, you know, he does enough work to earn his keep.
Rick March: let… he can stay, and we'll send him home on the Greyhound bus. So I started going to, this farm every summer.
Rick March: You know, it was a thing. As soon as school got out, they'd put me on the Greyhound, and I'd, you know, and they'd… the other people would pick me up on, you know, at the other end, and…
Rick March: I just got a kick out of living on this, on this, chicken farm.
Rick March: they had, Gravenstein apple orchard, they had boysenberries, they had, you know, so I earned a little extra money picking berries. He paid me the same as the outside pickers.
Rick March: And, you know, I had to gather eggs and help, you know, shake the feeders on the chickens and do various tasks, you know, help shovel the chicken manure out from under the, the, you know, where we, where we put it to…
Rick March: You know, to, become fertilizer.
Julie Stout: So, so, you know.
Rick March: You know, I… I, I… Kind of led 3 lives.
Rick March: I was a kid who was interested in being on a farm, and I… I had this ethnic community thing where we were speaking Croatian, you know, I… and then… and then I was a Hollywood high school student, you know, a junior high and high school student.
Rick March: And, I think that this contributed to the kind of mentality that made me become a folklorist.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: My grandmother liked to…
Rick March: talked to me. So I was the youngest kid, and I was around, and my mother was busy with her business, and my grandmother, you know, she had cataracts, and, you know, she was sitting, she was sitting in this easy chair, doing, hook rugs and crocheting and knitting.
Rick March: And I'd come home, and she was the only adult available to me a lot of the time then. And so, you know, I'd have a snack, and she'd start talking about
Rick March: Oh, yeah, you know, back in the old country, you know, we used to use the donkey to, you know, I would load up the donkey, and she'd describe, you know, the kind of,
Rick March: you know, thing that they, you know, the rack that they put on the donkey's back to tie bundles to, and, you know, she, you know, so I was also, you know, kind of hearing these stories. I think all of this stuff contributed to a mentality that resulted in me becoming a folklorist.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: And, When I, when I, Graduated from high school.
Rick March: the Vietnam War was going on, and if you didn't go right into college and get what was called a 2S deferment for full-time college students, you would be eligible to be drafted. You'd be 1Y… no, no, 1A. 1A was ready to, you know, fresh meat for the Army.
Rick March: Oh. And so, so, you know, I, I, I…
Julie Stout: Didn't really know what I wanted to study, but I went to UCLA initially.
Rick March: Staying at home.
Rick March: And part of the reason was, you know, there was this thing in the 60s with all the rock bands. In the early 60s, because my oldest brother had been kind of an acolyte of Pete Seeger and his music, and he played banjo, and he played union songs, my family was involved with the union movement.
Rick March: you know, this whole folk music thing, Peter, Paul, and Mary, Kingston Tree, all these were these, you know, I got interested in folk and bluegrass music, and I played guitar and mandolin, and the mandolin came because I was also playing ethnic music, Croatian music, on that.
Rick March: Anyway, the,
Rick March: Beatles came along, and they were on Ed Sullivan. We all, all us folkies.
Rick March: Got freaked out and said, wow, let's get electric guitars, you know?
Rick March: And so, I was in a rock band that was, you know, playing as a…
Rick March: as the local warm-up band for some, some, other, you know, like, we warmed up for… there was a band called The Doors that, had, Sky Jim Morrison, who became kind of a rock legend, died young, stupidly. One of my friends who was in bands with me, Kenny Edwards, became the main bass player for Linda Ronstadt's band through most of his
Rick March: his career.
Rick March: You know, there's a number… a number of musicians that I dealt with. We hung out at this folk club called the Ashgrove, and so a guy named Rye Cooter was a good guitarist and had a career. There was a guy that used the stage name Taj Mahal.
Rick March: who, you know, hung out there. So, you know, we… I was in this music scene, and that's why, although…
Julie Stout: In college, right?
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, yeah, my last years of high school and early… my first two years… so I wanted to stay in Hollywood at that time, because we hoped that our band would get, you know, a recording contract, and in those days, you couldn't…
Rick March: you know, the record companies had complete control. It wasn't like now, where you can get, you know, good digital recordings, you can do all sorts of stuff on your own, and put things up on the internet, and, you know, none of that existed. What you did was, you had to pay to go into a studio, get a tape made.
Rick March: Then you had to seal it up with all kinds of wax and string, and and then you mailed it to yourself.
Rick March: so that it had a copyright date stamped on it, so that you could prove that you… you had written the songs and stuff. That was… that was kind of… you know… Anyway.
Julie Stout: Did you, did you study, did you study music in college, or was this just a science?
Rick March: Yeah, I studied anthropology.
Rick March: I studied anthropology. I started out…
Rick March: I started out thinking, because my eldest brother was a physics professor, and my next brother started out in geology, and then he moved eventually to Slavic languages, but I started out as a biology major, because I really liked my biology teacher in high school.
Rick March: And then… and then I went into calculus, and I was… I was lousy. I wasn't the best math student. I, and then I… so I… I… I drifted, to anthropology. And,
Rick March: That was good, again, for getting me into the folklore,
Rick March: The UCLA had a professor in the anthro department named Ellen Dundees.
Rick March: who is a… became a well-known folklorist in that he was… used Freudian approach as his… his thing, and he was at,
Rick March: Oh, no, wait, well, no, he was… Dundee's was up at Berkeley, I misspoke. Yeah, it was Wayland Hand, who else was the…
Rick March: there were… there were a couple more people. Yeah, they had the John Edwards Memorial Foundation, there was a country music archive, at UCLA. Dk Wilgis, there's a…
Rick March: So there were these folklorists teaching at UCLA, and I took their courses as part of my anthro major.
Rick March: And then when I went up, after 2 years, all the action seemed to be moved up to the Bay Area. That's where all the cool bands, you know, the San Francisco hippie scene had started, the psychedelic bands, all this stuff. And… and then also all the political agitation,
Rick March: UCLA is kind of tucked away in this wealthy neighborhood, Westwood, and not close to things, whereas the Berkeley campus is right there in Berkeley, and there had been all, you know, the free speech movement, all this stuff, you know, which fired us up, you know.
Rick March: We'd hop in a car, you know, 4 or 5 of us, and drive up, you know, the 400 miles to Berkeley to participate in, you know, peace marches and, you know, civil rights-related things.
Rick March: So I, I was, I was, you know, ready to get out of my parents' house. And, so my junior and senior years, I was at Cal Berkeley.
Julie Stout: And.
Rick March: you know, that was… that was, influential on me, and I… I wound up using my music. I was in a street theater group called Agitprop.
Rick March: where we were… we were encouraging people to resist the draft for the Vietnam War, by… by doing these street theater little plays, and we went around, actually, to high schools and junior colleges.
Rick March: And had these little short plays that were 5 or 10 minutes long, because we'd, you know, illegally go onto the school campus.
Rick March: Present this play, pass out some leaflets, and then, you know, one of us was assigned to argue with, like, the… the vice principal that came out to kick us out to… until we were able to, you know, just.
Julie Stout: jump in the cars and go away. So, you know… Did you, during your degree, did you focus on, like, ethnomusicology a little bit, or was it… like, what was your focus in anthropology?
Rick March: Well, you know, there wasn't… there wasn't anything like what later became known as applied anthropology.
Julie Stout: Mmm…
Rick March: you know, it was all strictly teaching you to do an ethnography. Your goal was to go off to New Guinea or someplace, you know, parachute into a village.
Rick March: you know, hire a translator and, you know, interview people on their kinship systems. You know, that was the emphasis. And, I was… there was a… there was a right-wing
Rick March: superintendent of education for California at that time, who notably went on the news and said that our campus at Berkeley has become a four-year course in sex, drugs, and treason.
Rick March: And so, when people asked me what I was majoring in at Berkeley, I would always say, well, you know, the usual, sex, drugs, and countries, and…
Rick March: You know, I'm lucky, I'm lucky that I graduated. I did enough to pass all my courses, and I think my GPA wound up at 2.6, because I was spending all my time
Rick March: Going around, you know, doing all this, you know, move… you know, political movement-type things, you know, and…
Rick March: And so I was… I was the guitarist for the street theater group, and we made up all these songs, and you know, they were parodies of things, you know, like Gilbert and Sullivan.
Rick March: You know, we did one that was, called Moby Mao, the Great Red Whale, which was about that, that, you know, LBJ, Lyndon Johnson, the president at the time, was, was actually in Vietnam, you know, trying to start a war with China, you know, and so he had, you know.
Rick March: you know, Captain LB leading the… you know, we made up these metaphorical plays that… some of them were pretty good, it's too bad. I think… I think…
Rick March: one of them got recorded a little bit in a… a guy made kind of a low-budget exploitation movie about Berkeley weirdos, that they filmed us in… it's a little bit of one of our plays. It's in the Bancroft Library.
Rick March: in Berkeley, but I don't know if there's any copy of it anywhere else, and they wouldn't even let me take a screenshot of it, they'd let me watch.
Julie Stout: So…
Rick March: They were so strict about, you know, copyright issues. But anyway, yeah, so, you know, this was the environment I was in, and then I graduated, and it was, oh shit, now, now…
Julie Stout: What do I do?
Rick March: Now, there goes my draft affirmment. So, I thought that maybe teaching… there was this program in Los Angeles, in the Black neighborhood, in the South Central Los Angeles, which was generally called Watts nationally, because
Rick March: part of that neighborhood was Watts, and there was the Watts Riot in 1965. It was one of the first of these big urban riots. So anyway, I took a job where they were… they would hire anybody with a college degree.
Rick March: who was willing to start taking education-related courses to get a teacher's credential, you know.
Rick March: if you were willing to start teaching in schools in South Central LA. And these schools, you know, were, 90% to 99% African American students.
Rick March: And so I thought, hey, okay, I'll do that, and maybe that would be considered an essential enough occupation I could get a drafter from it.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: Anyway, I didn't work out at that. I… I… I wasn't, the principal was, you know, what we called in those days an Oreo. It was, you know, black on the outside, white on the inside. And he wanted… he wanted us to be… well, he said, Mr. March.
Rick March: The most important thing you have to, emphasize is classroom control. You know, if you have to spend, you know.
Rick March: 90% of your time on classroom control, which meant making the kids sit still and fold their hands, you know? You know, I want you to do it. In fact, you have to spend 100% of your time on classroom control, you know, so, you know, and I was trying to be the groovy guy that the kids would like, and so, you know, like,
Rick March: you know, I let them, when it was a rainy day and they couldn't go out on the playground for recess, I let them, you know, bring in their records and, you know.
Rick March: Things like that. I let them.
Julie Stout: What did you… wait, what did you teach?
Rick March: 6th grade.
Julie Stout: Oh, good! Like, 6th grade what?
Rick March: 6th grade, everything. There wasn't middle school then.
Julie Stout: Oh!
Rick March: K6, and then junior high was 7 through 9, and high school was 10, 11, 12.
Julie Stout: I see, I see. 6th grade, everything.
Rick March: So those were the oldest kids in the, in the elementary school.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And and I… I only… there was a… there was a, you know, a certified teacher that would come in that was assigned to three of us. The program, I assume, is called the Talent Search Program.
Rick March: There were, like, people who were talented at teaching, and he would come in, and he would show a, you know, he would show me how to create a particular lesson plan, and then he'd watch me do it, you know.
Rick March: And, about a third of the time, and then the other two-thirds, he was in the other two people's classrooms.
Rick March: And, and, you know, I was… I…
Rick March: basically, they gave me the opportunity to quit, or they were gonna fire me at a certain point. You know, like, I had said, instead of letting the kids… all the kids I knew lined up when the bell rang from the playground, and had to line up in order of height.
Rick March: Tallest first, shortest at the end, and then they had to, you know, I had to come downstairs and leave them into the school building, and they had to be one arm's length from the right-hand side of the hallway.
Rick March: And so, you know, you know, stupid young guy, I just said, hey, you kids are sixth graders, you're the oldest kids, you know how to come into the, you know, classroom without causing any disturbance, right? So I'm not going to come and lead you in. You know, you just, you know, when the bell rings, just come up quietly and come to the classroom.
Rick March: Okay, that lasted one day. You know, things like that, that I, I, so, so anyway, I got, I got fired.
Julie Stout: Wait, how long did you work there for, then?
Rick March: Oh, no, no, no, it didn't last that long, it was, like, 8 weeks, you know, or something.
Julie Stout: Oh, so it was fast!
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, so then I thought, oh shit, now what do I do? And I got advice from a guy who is a lawyer who is advising young guys like me on how to,
Rick March: Resist the draft, legally.
Rick March: And he said, you know, you gotta tangle up the Selective Service people with all of their bureaucratic regulations as much as you can.
Rick March: And, for example, with any communication you get from them, you have 30 days to respond. Wait 29 days, then send… respond with a registered letter. So, when they… they sent me my 1A classification, because I was no longer in college, he said, okay.
Rick March: Send them a letter that says, I appeal my classification. Do not say anything else.
Rick March: In that letter.
Rick March: And, so, you know, wait 29 days, I send it.
Rick March: So then they had to send back a letter saying, you know, on what grounds are you appealing it?
Rick March: And so, at that point, the lawyer said, hey, is there any state that you can go live in other than California, where you registered, for the draft? And I said, yeah, my brother lives in Wisconsin. My eldest brother was a physics professor in Wisconsin at that point.
Rick March: And so I said, Yeah, I could go to Wisconsin. He said, go there.
Rick March: So, from Wisconsin, you know,
Rick March: I was able to, you know, again, tie them up, And then…
Rick March: request that instead of having the California Appeal Board handle my appeal, the Wisconsin Draft Appeal Board could handle it.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: And California was having a ton of… a ton of hippies that were saying that they were conscientious objectors, meaning that, you know, I'm against all violence.
Rick March: And I am. But they were only recognizing people that were either Quakers or Jehovah's Witnesses, you know, in California.
Rick March: And they weren't familiar with that whole scene yet at the draft board and the appeal board in Wisconsin. So, I was able, in Wisconsin, to… they didn't give me the conscientious objector status, but they gave me a status called 1Y, which means we could take you if we want you, but
Rick March: at this point, we don't want you… yet. So, and that never changed for, you know, that never, never changed. So I got the, the, my, my going to… moving to Wisconsin.
Rick March: got me out of the draft. In the meanwhile, then, I met my girlfriend, who later became my first wife.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: you know, I took her at a certain point out to California, and we lived in California for
Rick March: You know, several months.
Rick March: And she didn't like it.
Julie Stout: Mmm…
Rick March: He didn't like it.
Rick March: And then… and then I had the, idea to go to what was then Yugoslavia, you know, Croatia was part of a bigger state called Yugoslavia at that time.
Rick March: And, she and I went there, and I studied… I went and I enrolled in a program called Ethnology, which was, you know, kind of like Anthro, except in Europe.
Rick March: the European Ethnology Department study their own nation's culture, for the most part. You know, we're different than anthropologists who tend to study, you know, at that time especially, cultures that were exotic from there.
Rick March: So…
Rick March: So, I studied for 3 semesters there. I started a band. Oh, where did… where did you go to school?
Rick March: University of Zagreb.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: University of Zagreb, and I was in the ethnology Department, and, you know, my wife and I, got a, a rented room.
Rick March: My family was all living down at the seacoast, which is, you know, pretty far from Zagreb on the island where my mom was from. So I would go down there and visit relatives sometimes, but, you know, I didn't have…
Julie Stout: Jude! Oh, I'm so sorry.
Rick March: Go ahead.
Julie Stout: Did you, know your relatives from before as well, or were you meeting these people for the first time?
Rick March: I met them for the first time when, let's see, it would have been 1967. I was about 19 was my first trip, and I met relatives in the home village.
Julie Stout: Okay.
Rick March: And then, yeah, so I, I, I, I bought a, a moped, if you know what one of those are.
Julie Stout: Like, the scooters?
Rick March: I bought a moped, which at maximum speed, you go about 25 miles an hour, and I used it to commute down to, you know, the village, you know.
Julie Stout: Oh, God!
Rick March: Or, you know, my wife didn't wind up staying. She got homesick and went back and was living with her mother. It wasn't a marital breakup at that point, but it was a kind of a sign of things to come, I think.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: You know, and, but, so, yeah, when my wife was still there, we took her bus and the ferry boat and so forth, but when I was on my own, then I just, you know, took the moped.
Julie Stout: Was your… was your family, like, still speaking Croatian at that point? Or was it mostly English, or…
Rick March: Well, which… the part of the family that was in… in, Yugoslavia was, of course, still speaking Croatian. My…
Rick March: After my mother… my grandmother died, my mother's mother died when I was 13.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And then my Aunt Marisa was still living with us for a while. After… after she moved out.
Rick March: And it was just my mother and me and my elder brother, English started to take over as the dominant language in the household, whereas Croatian had been more dominant when there was, you know, my mother
Rick March: her sister and her mother, there were, like, 3 native Croatian speakers in the family.
Rick March: there's me that had gotten it, you know, to a degree, as, you know, we kids would answer back in English often, you know?
Rick March: Yeah, I, you know, we… they'd say someday, you know, she'd…
Rick March: she'd say, you know, you know, she'd… my grandmother tell me, you know, buddy, it's time for you to go to bed, you know, or whatever, and I'd say, no, no, no, no, we called our grandmother Nona. No, no, no, I don't… you know, I'm not sleepy yet. You know, I'd say that in English, you know, whatever.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: But, you know, I spoke a dialect, an island dialect that I learned from home, and it was quite an adaption to learn the literary language, especially on an academic level, because what I learned was talk about, you know, what's for supper, you know.
Julie Stout: The everyday kind of language, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, and so… and… and the… even the syntax in the, you know, it's like an academic writing long sentences with three clauses, you know.
Rick March: And… in the… when I started at the University of Zagreb,
Rick March: The norm was that professors read from their notes
Rick March: And all the students copied it down verbatim. I am not kidding. That was of the Austro-Hungarian model, and you know, if you missed class, you would ask somebody, can you borrow their notebook, and then you copied it off of theirs.
Julie Stout: Oh…
Rick March: so, a lot of it was kind of a memorization through, you know, and why the professors just didn't publish their notes for the course, and of course, then they
Rick March: you know, to their way of thinking, they wouldn't be needed, I guess.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: But I did do field work in Croatia.
Rick March: And, you know, they would assign us things. I remember one where we had to do the… I went down with a guy. They would ask people who were students if they had any relatives in a village, and, you know, often they did. So I went with this guy down to see his relatives, and we had to study the customs relating to, you know, cutting
Rick March: hay, you know, with a sigh, you know. A lot of villagers still had, in the early 70s when I was there.
Rick March: didn't have mechanized equipment, and they'd go and they'd, you know, if they had small fields, they'd cut their hay down with a sigh. You know what I'm talking about, right?
Julie Stout: Yeah, I do know, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah. And, so we had to, you know, document
Rick March: you know, all the customs, and how the side was made, what they used to sharpen it, you know, what were the terms for all the parts of it, were there any, you know, like, songs or rhymes that were associated with cutting it? Were there any beliefs about, you know, you know, the affecting the weather, because you didn't want it to rain right?
Rick March: cut your hay, you know. So, sorry…
Julie Stout: Everyone assigned this one topic, or you were assigned this topic?
Rick March: No, no, that was, that we were,
Rick March: I needed to get a partner, since my relatives were kind of far away to get down to to visit, in the short term, I went with this guy who… whose relatives were in a village just outside of Zagreb, you know, maybe an hour bus ride. And, so,
Rick March: Yeah, so it was, it was asked, you know, we, we,
Rick March: you know, even as undergrads there, in that era, there was much more contact with the professors. The professors, all the exams were URLs.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: You would go in as a pair into… with a professor that… whose course you'd been taking, or there were teaching assistants, you know, like, a single teaching assistant who
Rick March: Shelly handled the whole course.
Rick March: And anyway, you'd sit down with them.
Rick March: And, you know, a little… in a little conference room. And, you know, the professor asked a question of one of you.
Rick March: And then they would say, oh, okay, Mr. March, do you have anything to add to what Mr. Markovich said? Or they actually call us colleague, Colleague Markovich. And I would say, well, yeah, I agree with what Colleague Markovich said, except, you know, I'd like to add this or that, you know.
Rick March: And then the next question would start with you and go to the other person.
Rick March: And then you had… a thing that constituted your transcript of record was a little booklet called an index, and, the professor would write in the date of you taking this exam and give you a mark right there, and .
Julie Stout: Right there.
Rick March: You better not lose that index, because that was your transcript, you know?
Julie Stout: That was up, yep, there it is, yeah. I had a quick clarifying question, if that's okay.
Rick March: Sure.
Julie Stout: So, you had your teaching experience, but that didn't go well, and then you went to Wisconsin. What sparked your want to get more schooling after that, and move to school in University of Zagreb?
Julie Stout: I'm very curious.
Rick March: Growing up with the whole ethnic tradition, I had wanted to go and… and do it, just because I, you know, I wanted to improve my language, learn the literary language, and actually, I had taken a couple of semesters of the literary language at Berkeley.
Julie Stout: I wasn't…
Rick March: totally… if I had only known my dialect, it would have been… it would have taken me longer to be able to plunge into classes. I probably would have had to take a, you know, a language class for foreign students for a year, but I didn't. I plunged right in. And,
Julie Stout: So you want to return to your roots, it kind of sounds like.
Rick March: Yeah, kind of, yeah, I'd heard all this stuff, you know. So, again, you know, all of this stuff was leading to me becoming a folklorist, in a way.
Rick March: So, you know, I mentioned my middle brother, and he had studied in Zagre before him. He was seven years… 7 and a half years older than me, and he had studied. So again, there was a family thing. He had married a gal from Croatia.
Rick March: And, then he was studying for his PhD at UC… no, no, at, University of Chicago in the Slavic department, where he eventually… he got his PhD there.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: So around the time that I went to Zagreb, he had been, for a couple of years, a professor at the University of Kansas in the Slavic department, and he, organized
Rick March: with an organization that kind of overlooks relations with Croatians abroad, you know.
Rick March: thing called Matitsa Iselianica, and he organized a summer language study seminar for students from around the country, could sign up, and they would get credits from the University of Kansas
Rick March: For doing this 6-week.
Julie Stout: language study program, you know, in Yugoslavia.
Rick March: And, so I had arrived
Rick March: And, you know, I was with my first wife, and they had, as part of the six-week thing, they spent a week
Rick March: Having a couple of vans, and taking students, so there was about 30 of them, 215 passenger vans, and took them on a trip around to see some interesting stuff, you know, for one of the weeks.
Rick March: And, there were a couple of spare seats on one of the vans, and so my brother said that, you know, my wife Mary and I could
Rick March: smuggle our way on the trip. We just, you know, we had to camp out when the students got to stay in a hotel, you know.
Rick March: We just… we camped out in a tent, you know? But… so we went on this trip, and on the van that we were in.
Rick March: There were, there was a guy who was a graduate student at Indiana, the Russian and East European Institute.
Julie Stout: Oh!
Rick March: And his wife, who wasn't a student,
Rick March: And I started talking to them, and they asked me, what are you doing? And I said, well, you know, I'm over here, I'm, you know, I've signed up to study ethnology, you know, at the University of Zagreb, and, you know, yeah, yeah. And he said, well, don't you know people get, like, fellowships and scholarships to do stuff like this?
Rick March: Oh, really? I didn't know. And, you know, so we chuckle.
Rick March: And then he went back to Bloomington.
Rick March: And he talked to people at the Russian East European Institute about, yeah, you know, I met this guy, you know, in Zagreb, and
Rick March: And, what I didn't know was at that time, you know, 1970s Cold War, everybody wanted to study Russian, and the Russian and East European Institute was
Rick March: anxious to get some more students to have some balance and more students in non-Russian languages, and so here I was, you know, somebody studying in what was called Serbo-Croatian.
Rick March: And I was really, I was really shocked and amazed that, you know, I don't know, a couple months later.
Rick March: I got a big package of all the, applications to apply to Indiana, and the Russian East European Institute, and the, let's say it was National Defense Education Act Scholarship, or something like that.
Rick March: Anyway,
Rick March: I… I was… I was amazed they… they spent $12 on airmail postage. Now, $12 in 1970 was about, like, I don't know, $35 an hour or more, I don't know. I… I thought, oh, crap, they must be serious.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: So, anyway, I was in the midst of my studies there, and so, you know, I sent them back a letter saying, yeah, I want to apply, but maybe I want to postpone it for a year, and I did. I, you know, I finished three semesters at Zagreb.
Rick March: And ultimately, I came back, I was offered, ultimately Ford Foundation, fellowships, Ford fellowships, to come to Indiana and study, at the… you know, so I was, I was… I was jointly…
Rick March: in the Russian and East European Institute and the Folklore Program.
Julie Stout: And this was all because one guy was like, you met him on the bus?
Rick March: Yeah, I'm.
Julie Stout: Man.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah.
Julie Stout: And then he was at IU, and then he said this to you, and then he sent you material. He didn't send it, the Institute sent it. The Institute sent it.
Julie Stout: And then you… okay, okay, okay.
Rick March: Lisa.
Julie Stout: Wow, small world!
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, I was just like, oh, okay. And I said, oh, well, shit, if they're… they're gonna… they're gonna give me this Ford Fellowship to come back to the U.S. and go to grad school.
Rick March: I'll do it. This sounds… and, you know, my wife had already gone back and was staying with her mother because, you know, she had gotten… she had gotten homesick for the U.S, and this and that, and we'd been separated for, you know, I don't know. I wanted to finish the project I was working on.
Rick March: We were apart for, I don't know, 7 or so months.
Rick March: And, the,
Rick March: So anyway, I came back to the States, we moved to Bloomington, we got, lodgings in what was then called Walnut Grove Trailer Park, which was
Rick March: big trailer… part…
Rick March: It was just on the north edge of campus between, you know, where the field house and the stadium are, and you know, the main part of campus. There's a big, you know, mobile home industry in.
Julie Stout: in the sun.
Rick March: So I guess the university bought a bunch of those. So we lived in there for a year, and then we got a little house that was available to rent in that same neighborhood. And so I wound up staying in Bloomington four years, because
Rick March: you know, the first two years, I was covered by these Ford Fellowships, from… through the Russian and East European Institute. I got my master's, you know, in folklore.
Rick March: and then the next 2 years, then I got, TA… I had half a TA and half an RA. The, the, the,
Rick March: I was… I was teaching for, Mary Ellen Brown was, teaching the Folklore 1A, or whatever it was called, you know, the intro, and, there was a bunch of us TAs, and then I… I just had one section instead of two, because my other thing was being in the Gary game.
Rick March: So the Gary gang was, you know… so again, I was supported entirely
Rick March: For 4 years of grad school.
Rick March: by these assistantships and fellowships, and every year I was thinking, oh, this is too good to be true, you know, it's not gonna last, and, you know, it… but, you know, it got me all the way through doing my… my, prelims.
Julie Stout: There you go.
Rick March: And, you know, and you know, it… it was…
Rick March: one of my main professors was Linda Dake, who was from Hungary, and was a very difficult personality to deal with. Another… Oh, yeah.
Rick March: Well, that, that European, arrogant, professor thing. And then, and then, you know, Dorsen, you know.
Rick March: liked me, and he had this thing in mind when he knew that I was fluent in Croatian, you know? That, because he had already done… he had already done a little bit of field work in Gary prior to applying for the Gary project.
Rick March: He had done a thing called, Is There a Hulk in the City?
Rick March: And, you know, we had very rigid guidelines, you know, at the time I came into the program. Like, Adrian Seward.
Rick March: freaked everybody out in this fieldwork seminar because she wanted to do a, her interviews over the telephone with somebody that was down in, I forget the state, Alabama or Georgia.
Rick March: And, and to us, it was like, oh my god, you know, can you… can you, you know, do an interview that isn't, according to the rules, exactly like so-and-so, likely in Kenny Goldstein's, you know, field workbook, you know?
Julie Stout: We had to read that, by the way, so…
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, there you go, you know, in which he encourages, folklorists to get, informants drunk, you know. Listen them up by, you know, making sure that… oh, well, anyway.
Rick March: So, so,
Rick March: You know, the fact that you could do… it was legitimate to do folklore research in the… in the city was… was considered, like.
Rick March: revolutionary, and… and Dawson was going to be the pioneer of that. And… and Dag had…
Rick March: done an article based on a couple of Hungarian-Canadian women who, spoke to each other on the telephone, and she said she did an article about… about, you know, you know, is there… is there, you know, oral…
Rick March: literature happening, you know, through telephone conversations, and that was another one.
Rick March: That… so, ugh.
Rick March: I guess, I guess what happened was,
Rick March: you know, because of… because of, you know, being a musician, because of, you know, having the language connection, because I… I was a noticeable
Rick March: grad student. There was a big group, I mean, there was, like, typically, you know, 30 of us.
Rick March: New students a year at that time.
Julie Stout: Oh, it's a lot of new students!
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, yeah, it… you know, and we were… we all had to take this pro-seminar from Dawson one semester, and then who taught us, you know, how to write footnotes, and, you know, how exactly to do field work, and, you know, all these kind of things.
Rick March: And, and then Glassie, who, you know, was… he was still at Indiana.
Rick March: before he went to Yale, and then Pennsylvania, and then came back to Indiana, you know, he, he, he was the, the guru for, oh, I'm, I'm the, the intellectual, you know, more philosophical end of, you know, what is, what is folkloristics all about, and,
Rick March: And, there was a real…
Rick March: Among the grad students, there was a real dividing up of
Rick March: who you were gonna kind of have as your main mentor. So, Dorsen had a set of people, Glassie had a set of people, Dag had very few, but a few.
Rick March: And I was just stubborn, and I wouldn't… I was a little bit older, and I just have a temperament where I wasn't gonna be that…
Rick March: subservient to any one particular professor, so I kind of… like, Warren Roberts had all his whole… he was… he… he was people who liked old tools, and and you know, how… how log cabins are constructed, you know, they all gravitated to him.
Rick March: But,
Rick March: So anyway, Dorsen… Dorsen, got me a, you know, part, assistantship because he wanted me to do field work in the Serbian and Croatian communities in Gary.
Rick March: And.
Julie Stout: And this was in your… your first semester at…
Rick March: No, no, no, no. I'd already gotten my master's. It was my third year at.
Julie Stout: Oh, so you're going into your PhD at that point.
Rick March: Yeah.
Julie Stout: Okay, okay. When you said the… you took, like, the… the first, like, seminar kind of course, I assumed that was, like, in your first year.
Rick March: That was. That was…
Julie Stout: Oh!
Rick March: That was. I mean, you know, I was… I was a student of Dawson's, and I took other courses from Dawson during my first two years.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: I took courses from Glassie, you know, during my first two years. I took courses from Dag. I took… then there were a lot of cross-listed courses. Felix Oynes was this Estonian scholar who I… I took Finnish folklore from him.
Rick March: Estonian and Finnish are kind of mutually intelligible languages.
Rick March: And then, I, I took, I'm trying to remember who else was a cross-listed professor.
Julie Stout: Topology courses at all?
Rick March: No, I didn't take any that were actually in Anthro. I figured I'd had plenty of Anthro as an undergrad. It was, it was mostly, people who were in other departments who were cross-listed in the… as… as… they were listed as… as…
Rick March: I forget what the term was, but they weren't… there were only a few people that were actually
Rick March: faculty of the folklore Department, and all these other people were people… oh, Ilhan Bashkos, who was a Turkish scholar.
Julie Stout: Oh, like, like affiliates or adjuncts?
Rick March: Yeah, they, they, they weren't adjuncts, they were, they were, they were, tenure-track professors, or full professors, who were, you know.
Rick March: I'm trying to remember the name of the guy that was in the English department who was an expert on… on Old English ballads, and so, you know, you could… that was cross-listed. Ilhan Bashkos was in, like, Uralic and Altaic Studies was the name of the department, and he…
Rick March: he was an expert on Turkish folklore.
Julie Stout: Oh!
Rick March: you know, other things. And, you know, so, so on and so forth, just as Felix Einus was, you know, in, I think he was in Uralic Altaic also. Yeah, I think that the Finns kind of… were… were classified in that.
Rick March: So… so yeah, there were all these area studies programs, I don't know if all of them still exist,
Rick March: Only,
Julie Stout: A few of them, a few of them still do.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, Indiana. Indiana was very strong in that, I think.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: Yeah, so, you know, the way I got into folklore was, you know, kind of happenstance, in a way.
Julie Stout: The guy, the guy in the bus.
Rick March: Yeah, I had, I had these courses in it. I took courses from Alan Dundees at… at Berkeley. Oh, and Amerigo Paredes. Dundee's went…
Rick March: Dundee's went to Denmark.
Rick March: On a… at his sabbatical year.
Rick March: And so, Paredes came from Texas to teach at Berkeley for a year, and I signed up for the class with him, and that was great. I took… I took everything he offered, you know, he took a… he taught a course each semester, and he was… he was… he was terrific.
Rick March: he, he… well, maybe because he was also a musician, and I… I related to his, you know, course, you know, he incorporated a lot of, Texas Mexican, corridos.
Rick March: And, just his… his wife, at the time was a noted, singer of,
Rick March: Mexican boleros, which is a, you know, a…
Rick March: you know, yeah, that was… so, you know, I'd had… yeah, I'd had a lot of contact with folklore, and then… then taking the… the ethnology courses. And actually, one of my Zagreb professors, Milo von Gavazzi.
Rick March: came to IU, and was at IU for one year as a visiting professor.
Julie Stout: Oh, so you had, like, a wide variety of different topics to take classes on and everything, it seems.
Rick March: Yeah, well, I only had Gavazzi when he was in Zagreb, but then when I found out from, you know, a long-term grad student, he said, oh yeah, he was here, you know, in such and such a year, you know, it was before I…
Rick March: it was… that was Bill McNeil, who later went to Arkansas, you know, so… Sute.
Rick March: Yeah, so, you know, how should I say? You know, when I…
Rick March: when I… when I had the… when I had the experience, you know, that we'll go into more depth, you know, at another occasion, with the Gary, gang.
Rick March: It really kind of hooked me on public folklore.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: You know, I still didn't really understand the possibility of a career in that.
Julie Stout: But the notion of spending my whole.
Rick March: career, you know, teaching a bunch of 18- to 20 year olds most of the time. And… and then, you know.
Rick March: what I didn't like about the kind of polemic nature of academic, you know, article writing and this and that is that
Rick March: You're very much what your product is, is your own career.
Rick March: You know what I mean? And… and you kind of build it by…
Rick March: Especially in that era, maybe it's different now.
Rick March: almost, you know, kind of debunking and building up on the back of somebody else, you know? It's like…
Rick March: Well, you know, the research on this topic so far by so-and-so and so-and-so and so-and-so is this, and that's just… that's okay as far as it goes, but, you know, you know, then you kind of…
Julie Stout: It's about filling the gaps, it's about…
Rick March: Well, it wasn't only filling the gaps.
Julie Stout: But, like, building up…
Rick March: So, this approach actually, you know.
Julie Stout: It's not.
Rick March: is erroneous, and, you know, my approach is better. And then there were these constant changes, like there would be fashions, like, oh, Victor Turner's inversions were in style now. You know, there was some… some professor
Rick March: you know, had made a mark, and some school of thought, oh, Levi Strauss's, you know, syntigmetic structuralism is, is, is, you know.
Rick March: No, that wasn't… no, his wasn't syndicancy.
Rick March: I forget, you know, because I found it… I found it a bit repugnant that there were these academic fashions
Rick March: Where a particular, a particular, theoretical approach
Rick March: would be fashionable, and then all of a sudden, everybody was writing their articles, you know, tailored to that approach. And if you didn't, then oh, you're out of it, you're… you're not up.
Julie Stout: to the time.
Rick March: You know, so… so, you know, I was already developing a certain amount of, you know, is this really for me? And that's when I thought, oh.
Rick March: you know, first working for… you know, I still hadn't imagined, you know, a career in public folklore, because there just were so few.
Rick March: And… But…
Rick March: You know, it was like, wow, you can go spend a lot of time doing field work, which is, you know, what really…
Rick March: Enriched my life.
Rick March: You know, the fact that, you know,
Rick March: I think… I think that, you know, you have to be a certain kind of a person that's open to a lot of uncertainty to kind of go in… into the field and, you know, find people that
Rick March: are the right ones to talk to about, you know, a particular thing, and then… and then what I particularly liked when I eventually got into, you know, public folklore work is it wasn't just so that I could write an article or a book.
Rick March: But it was… Something that that community wanted to do.
Julie Stout: No.
Rick March: You know, oh, we want to help organize a festival.
Rick March: We want to, we're, we're going to establish a little, community archive in your local library, you know, you know, we're going to, we're gonna, you know, there was a, there was, these local,
Rick March: cable access TV things that were starting up. Oh, we'll help you to get, you know, your local singers and dancers and whatnot, producing programs for your local cable access TV. You know, there were… you know.
Rick March: it wasn't my agenda only. I liked the fact that it was the agenda, you know, that I developed an agenda with the community that… and, you know, when I was working for the state agency, okay, well, let's see if we can apply for a grant and get you a little money to help you do it.
Rick March: Beautiful.
Rick March: So, you know, that was the direction, and I would have to say that, you know, the Gary gang was the genesis of that.
Rick March: For me. Again, you know, in part because I was working with,
Rick March: with urban people that were a little more… more hip. I remember when we… we went and we… we… we taped the service in,
Rick March: Prayer House of Faith was a Black church, and I was doing this, helping John Hasse, and, you know, we had more than one camera going, and, you know, we,
Rick March: And then we went into the minister's office, and, you know, with film, of course, there was this long delay when film had to get developed and stuff, you know, but we went into the minister's office, and he had a TV in there, and we hooked up our camera to the TV, and played it back, black and white and fuzzy, you know, by today's standards.
Rick March: He looked… We'll do that instead.
Rick March: how much does that thing cost? You know, he wanted to buy, he wanted to buy a video. He immediately saw the possibilities of, you know, oh my god, I can get my sermons and, you know, church services recorded and immediately available.
Julie Stout: Right, right.
Rick March: Yeah. So again, it was, you know, there was a… I did a lot of my field work locally. I did a… I did a paper on, I took an occupational folklore class, and I did one on the stone, quarrying industry.
Julie Stout: around.
Rick March: Bloomington and, you know, worked with a bunch of people there. As a musician, I was playing in a band with a local country musician, a guy named Don Pfeiffer, who lived in Bedford.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And, he, he, he, played at all the, like, Eagles Club, and Elks Club.
Rick March: a UAW Union Hall in Bedford, and there was…
Julie Stout: You know, we…
Rick March: playing down in, in, you know, you know, little, little towns playing country music. I was playing electric bass.
Rick March: mostly with his band. So, I did a lot of work
Rick March: You know, I was used to…
Rick March: having a certain kind of respect for the community where I was, and figuring out a way that I would fit in.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: Yam.
Rick March: And, and that's… that's what has enriched my life. You know, I… that's why, you know, today, here I am, eating at the Japanese,
Rick March: lunch, and I'd say a majority of my friends that I've made since I moved to Portland are Japanese American, because, you know, there aren't many Slavs in… no, there are a lot of Russians and Ukrainians, but there aren't many South Slavs here.
Julie Stout: There you go, there you go.
Rick March: Yeah, so… but, you see, my son lives in the Tokyo area, and my daughter lived in,
Rick March: They… you know, we can…
Rick March: Actually, I suppose this is part that won't go into the Gary Gang thing.
Rick March: Part of my job as the state folklorist in Wisconsin was to handle a state… a sister-state relationship.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: was established with Chiba Prefecture. Chiba is a prefecture in Japan, not far from Tokyo.
Rick March: And, so in the odd-numbered years, for about a decade, I was…
Rick March: hosting people from Chiba, and we'd find them homestays, and they would… they would be performers and artists, and, you know, take them to schools and community auditoriums and, you know, be involved in… in events. And then in the even-numbered years, I'd have to recruit a group of about 15 artists and performers to go to Chiba.
Rick March: Stay in homestays there, do the things in schools, festivals, you know, community auditoriums.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: That, that got my… my daughter especially interested in things Japanese, because I'd also have to bring, gifts to the Holmes family and bring back gifts from them. And she got… Sailor Moon was this cartoon that she liked.
Julie Stout: Anime, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, an anime, Hina Matsu, Hina…
Rick March: whatever her name was. yeah. And, so she wanted to be an exchange student to Japan, and she did, during her… between 11th and 12th grade, she went for 8 weeks and stayed with a family.
Rick March: And that family has a daughter who is only less than a year older than her, and they became friends, and there were visits back and forth. Anyway, that daughter, her friend, met my son.
Rick March: And one of the visits, and they got married, ultimately.
Julie Stout: The connection!
Rick March: Listen!
Julie Stout: Whoa!
Rick March: These things, they just happen, you know?
Rick March: So my son, you know, they lived in Torrance, California, because my… my daughter-in-law, you know, wanted to live where there were a lot of Japanese, and that's a… that's the town… that area of Los Angeles has the most Japanese.
Julie Stout: Oh.
Rick March: And then she kind of got homesick for her relatives, and my son said, well, I better go to… before I get too old, go to Japan and learn Japanese so I can talk to my in-laws. So they went for one year.
Rick March: 2014. Well, they never came back.
Rick March: I mean, they'd be back for business, but…
Julie Stout: They fully live there in Japan, though.
Rick March: So my son and daughter-in-law, you know, he wound up getting a job, he works on an Air Force base, and the credit union is a financial advisor, and you know, blah blah blah, and he…
Rick March: He thinks he's doing better than he possibly could in the U.S, and his wife became a construction site engineer, which is pushing the envelope in Japan, which is more misogynistic about women getting.
Julie Stout: Right, right.
Rick March: field.
Rick March: And, but, you know, she got spoiled by her years in California, becoming more feminist. And,
Rick March: The, so… so, yeah, they, they,
Rick March: One of the things that… that…
Rick March: you know, influenced my life was the things that came through my work as a folklorist in Wisconsin.
Rick March: It changed my whole family's trajectory to a big interest in Japanese culture. Both of my kids are fluent in Japanese, especially my daughter, who then went and got a master's at University of Chicago in East Asian studies, emphasis on Japan, and her professors all encouraged her to go to PhD programs.
Rick March: But they encouraged her to apply, like, to Harvard and Princeton and so forth. And thankfully, she says she didn't get in, because she… she… he didn't write… she wouldn't write in Pomo.
Rick March: talk. She hated pomo and Poe Pomo and all this stuff, and she did a… she did a master's thesis about, the way sumo wrestling evolved in art from
Rick March: Woodblock prints to… Newspaper sports sections, and…
Julie Stout: Oh, interesting!
Rick March: Yeah, it was, was, was interesting. She's, she's a sumo fan.
Rick March: and gets up at 3 a.m. to watch, you know.
Julie Stout: Watch actual matches and everything. Yeah. That's awesome.
Rick March: So my whole family, you know, I always thought our involvement would be with Croatia, because, you know, in my…
Julie Stout: You're in Japan.
Rick March: But my family is actually, you know, involved with Japan, which is fine. Her generation lives in the whole world, you know?
Julie Stout: It's, it's… it grows, the interest grows across different places.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, yeah, and I, I, I've had, like, 8 visits to Japan.
Julie Stout: Wow!
Rick March: Maybe, maybe, I'd have to count, but…
Julie Stout: That's awesome!
Rick March: Yeah.
Julie Stout: I had a… okay, so… just so…
Julie Stout: When you, finished your PhD at Bloomington, correct?
Rick March: Yeah.
Julie Stout: What made you want to go back to Wisconsin to do public folklore? Why Wisconsin in particular?
Julie Stout: Oh, you're white.
Rick March: Okay, she was… I met her in Wisconsin, she was, you know, born in.
Julie Stout: Oh, she's from Wisconsin!
Rick March: She was in Wisconsin. So, when I, when I came back from Zagreb, the place to come back to, was where my wife was, and, you know, and then, so that's what, that's what,
Julie Stout: That's what triggered that move again.
Rick March: Yeah, except then we went… we went, we went down to Indiana from Wisconsin after I got back. So I… she was living in Wisconsin. I got back, there was some months delay until this next school year started, and I, you know, we… we went down to Bloomington.
Rick March: And we were in Bloomington 4 years.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: 73 to 77.
Rick March: And, You know, the last 2 years being involved with the Gary.
Rick March: And, And then,
Rick March: Let's see, where in the heck did I wind up? Yeah, then I… then I wound up… I worked for a while at…
Rick March: Getting contract work, Bess Hawes knew me from having hired me
Rick March: In 76, there was the Bicentennial.
Julie Stout: And they had an.
Rick March: 11-week-long festival of American Folklife on the Mall in Washington, D.C.
Julie Stout: Oh!
Rick March: And they were looking under rocks for folklorists who would develop programming for that. And so, you know, she knew that I, you know, spoke Croatian, and so I got,
Rick March: you know, hired on contract for Smithsonian to, you know, go around and find participants to be in the festival. Some of them were people from Gary that I'd met.
Julie Stout: Oh, beautiful! Yeah, nice.
Rick March: Then others, I went to other cities, Cleveland, yeah, see what,
Rick March: Cleveland, Detroit, other, other cities with big South Slavic populations.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: And they, they, they all went out to, to Washington. And,
Rick March: So Bess was favorably impressed. Bess was also noted in, you know, the… she's the,
Rick March: sister of Alan Lomax, and they were involved in that whole kind of left-wing folklorist thing, and the union thing, you know, Woody Guthrie and Union songs, and she knew my dad.
Julie Stout: A little bit. The connection!
Rick March: And knew of my dad's connection to… as an important union leader. And, you know, it's kind of like Laurel Horton, who was another one that Bess knew through her dad, Miles Horton, from, you know, about the Highlander School in Tennessee.
Rick March: So, there were some of us that were from… the kids of…
Rick March: associates of the kind of left-wing folklorist scene that Bess Hawes was part of, and and you know, she… she wound up recruiting us. She, you know, she, you know, initially.
Rick March: to do… you know, if an organization wanted to get a National Endowment for the Arts Folk Arts grant, they needed to have a folklorist as an advisor on the project somehow, either to do folklore field work with them, or just, you know, as a consultant, or, you know, so there were these jobs
Rick March: that, you know, every… every NEA grant, she was… she was shoveling work
Rick March: our way. So, I was surviving… I was living in Milwaukee at the time.
Rick March: With first wife, and my son was born.
Rick March: A few years later, my daughter was born.
Rick March: And we,
Rick March: you know, we're getting by on ice having part-time jobs that would often let me, you know, I'd say, oh yeah, I'm working half-time, can you give me… I'll work full-time for 2 weeks, and then can I have time off because I'm hired to do this field work in Idaho?
Rick March: For this organization. Yeah, so I did that for about 6 years. You know, but then, you know.
Rick March: it took a while to… because you had to have matching funds and stuff, it took a while to develop an organization that wanted to have a full-time folk arts, you know, state folklorist, and it turned out to be the Wisconsin Arts Board. And, you know, I applied for it, and I got the first
Rick March: you know, crack at it, which was cool, because there never had been a state folklorist, and so I got to make up what a state… you know, as long as I could present the ideas to my director and to the board.
Rick March: And they said, oh, okay, that's good.
Rick March: you know, I got to invent it. And so I involved a lot of field work and so forth in the process, and then Bess had also created the apprenticeship program the very first year that I started.
Rick March: first year of what was called Folk Arts Apprenticeships, and they were run out of D.C. at first. Everybody had to apply to the NEA, and it turned out to be totally unworkable. And so she farmed it out to the states.
Rick March: And so I, you know, was in the first year that the states had it, and she asked people to have a specialization.
Julie Stout: And I had met some people at a…
Rick March: at a, native, you know, tribal arts festival in Eau Claire, Wisconsin.
Rick March: they… I talked about, hey, I got this apprenticeship program.
Rick March: what do you think if we put an emphasis, you know, on native traditions as the focus? You know, some people didn't have any, but Bess was encouraging a focus, so then that gave me a reason to work with the 11 tribes and bands, plus the urban Indians in Milwaukee.
Rick March: And, and then, you know.
Rick March: that developed a whole set of, you know, associations, and, you know, I was always very careful as a government guy to never promise more than I could deliver. So if I was saying, you know, yeah, there are some grants, but
Rick March: I'm not deciding, you know, there's a panel of people. I can give you advice on how to write this.
Rick March: I can give you advice on how to budget it, but, you know, you may get it, you may not. And, and so I was… I was always very careful, and… and I also, you know.
Rick March: I had learned enough… I think that my… growing up in these kind of multiple cultural settings, you know, living with the people from Missouri who were, you know, I jokingly called them, intellectual rednecks.
Rick March: Because, you know, they were… they were from a very much, you know, Highland South culture of Missouri, but they were individuals who read a lot of, like, philosophy books and things.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: and, the…
Rick March: you know, what I liked about being on the farm was, you know, every meal was a big discussion, you know?
Julie Stout: We'd sit there.
Rick March: and discuss, you know, all sorts of stuff. And so, you know, I… I knew how they were different culturally, and I could fit in with them in their, you know, essentially upland South Missouri culture. Then my, my, my fam… my own family's Croatian culture,
Rick March: I went to this Unitarian church where there were a lot of youth group kids who were from a variety of backgrounds, including a lot of Jewish kids. My dad was Jewish. My dad… my dad was an atheist.
Rick March: and minimized his Jewish connections, because he said, well, you know, Judaism's a religion, and, you know, my family's from Poland and Lithuania, you know?
Rick March: you know, he wasn't interested in that. But, you know, I knew just, again, because of, you know, who were a lot of the political radicals, a lot of them were from Jewish background.
Julie Stout: And so I already, just growing up, had these multiple cultures that.
Rick March: you know, I navigated in. And then, you know, doing field work in Gary, doing… and, you know, I wasn't only… the part of Chicago we lived in, in the Kenwood neighborhood, was one of the few, kind of.
Rick March: racially integrated area, so I, you know, I was used to dealing with Black kids, you know, growing up. And, so, you know, I was helping John Hassey, you know, working in the Black community. Not that I had any, you know, you know, it was just that
Rick March: I was at ease in Black communities where, you know, John, who… who,
Rick March: you know, grew up out in, was it South Dakota, or,
Rick March: trying to remember. I know he went to college in, you know, rural Minnesota, and so on and so forth, and was just fascinated by Black people, but didn't have much experience with them.
Julie Stout: You know?
Rick March: So… so again, you know, I… I was just very fortunate that my life path took me into contact with a lot of different cultures, and… and then…
Rick March: Wisconsin is a very culturally diverse state, despite being, you know, well, more than 80% white, but the…
Rick March: specific European traditions have remained very strong.
Rick March: generations, people are very conscious of being German-American, or Polish-American, or
Rick March: American, you know, and it still relates to
Rick March: social life, like, you play different card games. If you're a Norwegian-American, you play Euchre, but if you're a German-American, you play Sheep's Head, which is another.
Julie Stout: or.
Rick March: Belgians play a game called Kuyu. You know, like, even these card games have persisted in ethnic context.
Rick March: And, and then,
Rick March: One of the things I did when I worked on the farm is,
Rick March: this guy, Bob Pepper, that I stayed with, he took a job for a while working for, the Farm Workers Union over in Modesto, and so I went over there with him, and I worked, you know, farm work jobs, mostly with Mexicans.
Rick March: No Mexican-Americans, for the most part.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: the Unitarian youth group went down to Mexico one summer, and I went with them. We stayed in Jalisco, in a little town where a rich lady who was a member of the congregation
Rick March: owned a, an orphanage, and we… they're, making an irrigation system for the orchard. They were… so, you know, I spent a summer in Mexico, even though I took French in high school, which was… Well, whatever, I can speak some French. I learned a lot of Spanish, and…
Julie Stout: Meaning.
Rick March: And… and plus being in California, you're around a lot of… a lot of kids that were Spanish-speaking. So, you know, I… I just… I just was lucky to have this,
Rick March: plethora of cultural inputs into my life that made me comfortable with, plunging myself into… You know, my big brother, who…
Rick March: he's passed away now, I can speak a little bit this way, who tended to be a socially awkward guy. He was a really brilliant genius physicist, but, he was probably… he was… he was,
Rick March: You know, bullied a bit and marginalized as a brain in those days, you know, when you…
Julie Stout: wrong.
Rick March: You know, and so, he, he said, oh, you know, my little brother here, you know, if the Martians landed, he'd be, he'd be sitting there, you know, hanging out, learning Martian customs, you know. He said, what's about me?
Rick March: Whatever.
Rick March: whatever. So anyway, this is kind of… this kind of, you know, I think we've… we've talked longer than… than the hour and a half, but I don't want to…
Julie Stout: No, it's okay. Yeah, my,
Julie Stout: How long did you act as State Focalist for Wisconsin again?
Rick March: 26 years.
Julie Stout: 26 years.
Rick March: I… I was offered being deputy director of the.
Julie Stout: agency.
Rick March: two times.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: you know, I was thinking about it, you know, it was some more money, and I went to talk to another guy who had been a folklorist who had… in Indiana, I think, yeah. Jeff, god, what was his last name?
Rick March: I forget now. Anyway, I was at a regional folklore gathering, and I asked him, I said, well, you know, you went ahead and took, like, a deputy director job.
Rick March: you know, how do you like it? They said, well, you know, you have to make up your mind. Do you want to, you know, continue being a folklorist, or are you interested in being an arts administrator?
Rick March: And I said, thank you, you answered my question.
Rick March: And.
Julie Stout: Here we go.
Rick March: And I, you know, I actually realized, deputy director, you get all the tasks that the director doesn't want to do. You had to do, like, annual performance or 6 months performance evaluations of your co-workers. You had to, you know, you were stuck in the office, you were, you were, you know, answering voicemail and emails all the time, you know.
Julie Stout: Administrative stuff, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, you know, going over, you know, all kinds of, you know, forms and shit. And and so, you know, they off… I turned it down that time. Then a couple years later, they offered it to me again, and I… after I turned it down the second time for a different director.
Rick March: They realized, oh, this guy, you know…
Rick March: He, he, you know, we, we, you know.
Rick March: It wasn't enough money to make me want to stop, you know, being in the field.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And, it was just…
Rick March: I can say that until the very end, when I was really ready to retire.
Rick March: that I never got up in the morning and said.
Rick March: Ugh, I have to go to work.
Rick March: it was always like, oh, I can hardly wait to get down to the office, because, you know, I gotta see how that thing, you know, with the group up at Eau Claire is happening. You know, I hated it when they started clamping down more bureaucratically. I knew what my travel budget for the year was, and I'd stretch it, you know, in a way that was a little, a little on the, you know, edgy side.
Rick March: people invite me to stay, so I said, I'm gonna save, you know, the hotel money.
Rick March: You know, if it wasn't somebody that was directly applying for a grant or something, you know, I'd stay with somebody and, you know, when I had to be overnight.
Rick March: there were, you know, all kinds of ways.
Rick March: that, you know, I liked the fact
Rick March: that, like, okay, so the Arts Council in Wausau, in central Wisconsin, would call me up, you know, let's just say, hey, you know, Rick, there, we're having a big board meeting coming up, or we have to make some decisions about X, Y, and Z, you know, because again, it was folk and community, so I was dealing with the community arts broader than just folk arts.
Rick March: They said, we, you know, could you attend our board meeting and give us some advice and discussion of these… these issues? And so, you know, I say, okay, when is it? And they'd say, you know, yeah, next week, Thursday, blah blah blah. I'd look at… I'd look at my calendar, I'd look at my travel budget.
Rick March: And I'd… I'd be able to tell them, yes, yeah, I can make it.
Rick March: Then, you know, the Department of Administration for the state started clamping down, and so, in order to go to that meeting in Wausau, I would have had to fill out a bunch of forms. It would say.
Rick March: What agency goals and objectives are you fulfilling by attending this meeting?
Julie Stout: Mmm…
Rick March: And, you know, when is it? How much is it gonna cost? And then you had to pass that memo along to somebody at the Department of Administration, and wait for them to approve it. And it might take 2 weeks, you know, and they usually approved it, but sometimes they didn't.
Rick March: you know, I mean, I knew how to write bureaucratic bullshit enough to fit it in with one of the goals and objectives of the agency, so it usually would pass, but, you know, it was like…
Rick March: I started to hate the increasing, you know, control level that.
Julie Stout: Oh, my God.
Rick March: you know, I felt like, hey.
Rick March: I know how to represent my agency. You know, I go to the board meetings, I know what our agency objectives are. I know, I know what my budget is. I'm not gonna go over budget.
Julie Stout: If I run out of travel money before the end of the fiscal year.
Rick March: that's, you know, that's terrible, because it means I can't go anywhere for, you know, for months. So, you know, I figured it out.
Rick March: So anyway, that gives you an idea, then, of, you know, why I stayed in the… as the folklorist.
Rick March: And I also, eventually, when I hit 62, I was really,
Rick March: one of the things I couldn't do, I had some books in mind that I wanted to write.
Rick March: And, when I hit 62 and was eligible to go, you know, on pension and so forth, I took early retirement. I didn't wait till 65. And I also felt it was good for us to open up some of these folklorist jobs to younger colleagues, because, you know.
Rick March: I, I could do it!
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Rick March: I could do it. So, you know, so I retired and, you know, I wrote the folklore, the two folklore books first, one on Croatian music, and then one on polka.
Rick March: And they got published, and then my wife, my second wife, I'd gotten divorced, and I met a woman in Wisconsin who was a history professor, and we're…
Rick March: We're now married for 20 years, and you know, very compatible. And she urged me to write about my family's history, and I did. I wrote a book that got published,
Rick March: called A Great Vision about our, you know, growing up in a radical family, the stuff I've been talking about, except in
Rick March: different emphases. A lot of it emphasized my dad's, you know, days as a union organizer. He survived.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: Nation attempts and stuff, so it has some dramatic things.
Rick March: So I wrote, I retired at 62, and I wrote the three books, and got them published in the 6 years, and I said, oh shit, now what do I do? But I've been doing some more writing, and I've been doing some… I also, if you're curious.
Rick March: I wound up producing about 10 YouTube videos on vintage Japanese music. I started a music program at the senior lunch where singers, you know, I met 3 other people who play music.
Rick March: And then some of the immigrants from Japan, you know, they miss singing songs that they learned as kids at school, or that were on the radio when they were in Japan before they emigrated.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: And so they suggested songs, and my friend John doesn't mind spending hours on the computer finding the words and music to these songs, and we print them out, and we do these things. So I learned quite a bit about vintage Japanese music.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: somebody brought in, you know, there's a lot… a table with giveaway stuff at the senior lunch. Somebody brought in a box of old 78 discs.
Julie Stout: Of Japanese music.
Rick March: And of course, you know, I had a program called Down Home Dairyland on Wisconsin Public Radio for over 30 years, actually. I continued it, actually, when I was in Oregon still.
Rick March: So I took the 78s home, and, you know, the ones that were in decent shape, I made digital recordings of, and the director of the lunch program said, hey, what do those records sound like?
Rick March: And I thought, oh, I could send her some files, and I thought.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: I'm gonna make a fake radio program using those files. And so I asked my wife to record a fake station ID. You're listening to Radio WINK, the voice of a corny guy. Dong, dong, dong, you know.
Rick March: Thomasana, Japanese instrument.
Rick March: And so, anyway, I made this fake radio program and made a selection of those records. And people really liked it. She put it on, like, the sound system in the room.
Rick March: People really liked it. And a younger woman, Ame Hayashi, who was coming occasionally to the senior lunch she was working, she had flexible hours because she and her husband were working on a biography of a famous sumo wrestler.
Rick March: Oh! Yeah. Yeah. So, anyway.
Rick March: I think she's still under 40. So, you know, people in your generation are able to make videos, you know, in their sleep, I think. So she said, I can turn your soundtracks into videos.
Rick March: And I said, well, let's go for it. And so she found stills and videos, video clips, of these vintage artists from the 30s, 40s, 50s, you know, and we put them… put them on YouTube, on the ecoinda card, the lunch program, as a YouTube channel.
Rick March: And so we put them on there, and I started getting favorable comments. I got comments from Japan, you know.
Rick March: Sometimes written in English, sometimes in Japanese, and you know, they're saying, oh, we have nothing like this in Japan, you know, and okay, good.
Rick March: And
Rick March: Yeah, so I'd encourage you, you know, I can, I can email you a link, to, to the Koinokai, YouTube channel.
Julie Stout: Yes, please.
Rick March: So my last burst of creativity after I finally stopped making Down Home Dairyland programs, I stopped after my 76th birthday.
Julie Stout: I decided.
Rick March: You know, I'm just getting a little tired of having to produce 4 or 5 hours of radio a month.
Julie Stout: news.
Rick March: you know, public stations in Wisconsin. I was just doing it for free.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: And some of the stations are still playing my reruns, but I also helped recruit a younger woman who's, you know, doing… who's mostly polka.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: And,
Rick March: But, my last big burst of creativity was on making, you know, learning a whole bunch about vintage Japanese music and making these videos.
Julie Stout: Yeah, no, I love that, yeah.
Rick March: Yeah, so yeah, you might want to watch one of them, or whatever. One of them… one of them was related to a singer that was being featured on a… on a,
Rick March: Japanese TV Morning Cereal program, you know, where they.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: Of, like, they had 20 minutes a day on the story of this person's life.
Julie Stout: And so I made a… I made a program about her.
Rick March: And that one got 9,000 views, you know, you know, which, you know, pretty good for a…
Julie Stout: That's pretty good!
Rick March: esoteric subject. The others, you know, eventually… some of them had, you know, in the thousands, and then it kind of slowed down. I think the algorithm gets tired of you. That's right. Some of them are just in the hundreds, but, you know, I don't care, it was just for fun.
Julie Stout: No, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Julie Stout: So, I think that we are getting closer to time, but I want.
Rick March: Yeah, let's…
Julie Stout: Just one last question, if that's okay. Yeah, sure.
Rick March: Absolutely.
Julie Stout: So, you had a very eventful life, to say the least, in a very, interesting academic and then public folklore career. And my last question for you is, how do you view your academic and public folklore, like, legacy? How do you view your life as a legacy, if at all?
Rick March: You know, I, I think, I think my contributions are important.
Rick March: all of my radio programs for Wisconsin Public Radio are archived at the Mills Music Library, you know, the library that's associated with the School of Music at the University of Wisconsin, and researchers have come there, you know, from around the world.
Rick March: To use, you know, those things, not just my radio programs, but my radio programs provide a useful
Rick March: avenue into more specific stuff, because, you know, they were thematic, so if you're looking for old Finnish recordings, they can look at one of my Finnish things and get, you know, 6 or 7 artists who were featured in the radio program, and then know how to go and find their earlier recordings.
Julie Stout: Mmm.
Rick March: So, you know, I feel like I've done that. The book, the Polka book was published by the State Historical Society Press, and it was the only kind of
Rick March: You know, it was… it was academically respectable insofar as I had to make footnotes, but, you know, I wrote it… I wrote it for a general audience.
Julie Stout: Hmm.
Rick March: And I did it in collaboration with an excellent photographer, and it sold a lot, and is in public libraries all over the state, and other states nearby. Same thing, you know, with my Croatian music book, you know, it was…
Rick March: It was… it was more academic, because it was for University of Wisconsin Press.
Rick March: And, but again, it was kind of the… the only, the only book in English about this particular music tradition.
Rick March: And so, you know, I feel like I've made, you know, it's not a huge contribution, there's lots of people that, you know, Durson has published 50 books or whatever he did, but, you know, I published a couple of important ones, plus the… I thought my family history book has…
Rick March: you know, it sold fairly well, and it's… it got a lot of notice on, kind of, left-leaning websites, like Portside and, God, what's the name of that, anyone, Jacobin, and, things like that. So, you know, so it has…
Rick March: You know, I, I feel like, you know, I've left a trail where, you know.
Rick March: my contributions won't be, totally, totally forgotten about, but of course, I'm not really interested. I'm, hanging around all these Japanese have made me too much of a Buddhist to, you know, be too attached to the things of this world, you know?
Julie Stout: And it kind of reminds me of, I feel like someone does public folklore in order to make an impact on people in the community, and I feel like even if your tangible legacy is through these books, I think that… would you agree that the impact that you've made is more, like, interpersonal?
Rick March: Absolutely. And the folklore program at Wisconsin has been strong. Our agency was cut by… when this horrible, you know, we didn't have the word Maggie yet, Governor Scott Walker came in. He cut the arts agency by 73%.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: We had 13 employees, it went down to 4.
Rick March: One of those four that was retained was the folk arts person as a full-time employee, and the folk arts program at Wisconsin has continued to this day.
Julie Stout: There you go.
Rick March: You know, with,
Rick March: Oh, yay, yay. I'm spacing her name now, but anyway, the,
Rick March: Caitlin, Caitlin Bur… Burr, byrne? Byrne? Yeah.
Rick March: So we, we, she was, I think, a Western Kentucky graduate. Anyway, we, we,
Rick March: Yeah, I, I was, I was, along with, like, the guy in New York, Bob… oh, hell, it's hard to get old, you, you forget people's names. But,
Rick March: I was one of the leaders of the state folklorists. We went to Bess Haas and said, hey, we can't keep coming to AFS every year. We need to go
Rick March: to National Assembly of State Arts Agencies, where we can advocate with the agencies that we do business with. And the first time we did it was in 88 in San Francisco, and Archie Green and Bess came to talk to us. Archie Green's the occupational folklore guru.
Rick March: That, Was a big, you know.
Rick March: Yeah, yeah, I, I consider myself as one of a cohort of several leaders of the public folklore, scene that… that… that…
Rick March: pulled us together, you know, as a cohesive force in cultural work in the country. And, you know, resulted in the book called Cultural Work, and so on and so forth, that Tim… Tim Franning was, you know, one of those ones from Western Kentucky I mentioned to you.
Rick March: Who pulled that together.
Julie Stout: Yeah, and…
Rick March: Yeah, like I said, you know, we weren't working on our own academic careers so that we had a, you know, big, you know, load of publications, but we had some significant ones. And we have,
Rick March: made, you know, whatever, by whatever name it goes, public folklore, and ongoing, and surviving, despite its fact that it's, you know, under attack, you know, it's DEI, and so on and so forth.
Rick March: Yeah, what we do, basically, is DEI. It defines us. You know, we're trying to call attention to diverse cultures and include them in the national narrative, you know. So, it's absolutely,
Rick March: Something that, is contrary to, you know, white nationalism and so forth.
Rick March: Right.
Julie Stout: Right.
Rick March: And so there's no way, there's no way in this, you know, politicized environment that…
Rick March: You know, we can't say that, you know, what we've done is important to
Rick March: You know, the cultural, makeup of our, of our country, and…
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: I'm proud to have, Done a lifetime of work, career worth of work in that.
Rick March: And I'm very lucky. I'm very lucky to have had a job that, as I said, I… I,
Rick March: enjoyed, you know, right up till right at the end when I was feeling like, okay, it's time for me to retire and work on those books and give the job to somebody else.
Rick March: Right up until that point, it's…
Rick March: it was… it was a joy of a career. It was.
Julie Stout: Yeah.
Rick March: You know, and so, I encourage you as a, as a young colleague to, you know, wherever you wind up in, you know, some combination of whatever they call library science these days.
Rick March: Information tech and whatever, and, and folklore to, to, you know, keep that, that, that cultural component that we learn through folklore, that valuing of, of all the diverse cultures of the world that, you know, that we learn, you know, you know, keep that as part of your life and work.
Julie Stout: Yeah, yeah.
Julie Stout: I couldn't agree more.
Julie Stout: So, I'd love to do a follow-up interview, but I think I'm good to end this here if you are, unless you have anything else you want to add.
Rick March: Yeah, I think… I think we had talked about, sometime on Sunday afternoon, if that… unless you want to take some time to, digest this part, and then reschedule later.
Julie Stout: Yeah, let me end this recording here really fast, and then.
Rick March: Okay.
Julie Stout: Thank you.
Rick March: Card off the recording, okay.
Rick March: And do you have a good.